welcome to this video first first game
in the session and I got him again the
yard bird okay oh well maybe maybe go
for something else here I didn't know
what he does against and Kings Indian
okay I'm probably on 92 actually okay I
couldn't try this super aggressive f5
business against this which is some yeah
maybe a bit dubious but it is definitely
a very very sharp so let's see I think
Knight f6 i recently lost the game with
that okay it's not playing f3 here hmm
okay okay i'm still going to push this
you cannot go Bishop g4 so let's just
push the kingside came so g5 if he takes
their 9 p-5 i have looked f6 to cover
then at the end maybe then you can't go
Bishop g4 hmm ok now i'm not an expert
Robert around those borders and I think
maybe maybe you can take d6 here and no
it just stops this interesting okay I
have to go here anyway I guess
interesting way to play okay so come
really have to switch off the phone when
I play I totally hate that and usually I
just lose because this distraction
completely kills my back composure so
let's see here on quite often they take
here but I don't really know what this
is such a case let's just go here
and that's that it's kind of weird that
germ that f3 it's not play gym yeah I
have to go Bishop f8 but at the moment I
can't cover that and it's not snot that
in the not simple i think for wide at
least that's what I hope I think roocase
six is the possibility it looks a bit
sick but how does he continue from here
taking on d6 something violent I don't
know one thing that's important is he
cannot easily go nite be five or
something as efore Hanks maybe he still
can't do it somehow technically but he
has to think about this kind of
procedure ya know I have night h form as
a possibility for f3 yeah I know that b6
is kind of hanging but okay f3 is
something he has to react you
Knight b6 is very very strong once it
hits oh man maybe you just plays f3 here
in this position
probably 90 x b 6 is still still there I
don't really see what I do against f3
down okay so he allowed f3 hmm maybe
maybe you can do that okay I have to
play it anyway an oblique use and
pretending there might be something else
there isn't if he takes eh i takee to
wear's and this is a double check I
don't really understand why he allowed
it I get to take Bishop th3 and well I'm
really in the game now check I'm
probably more than that okay so how do i
how do I go about this g-form may be
immediately it's got king-8 2nite age 54
Queen h4 that's pretty strong that looks
pretty strong
I'm surprised he allowed f3 really this
is something I definitely wouldn't have
done King edge too i play Knight age 54
queen age for that must be must be good
really if he takes it two nite chicks
yeah I don't know maybe if you take that
I should play rock g7 that's may be
stronger for Luke g4 or 94 depending on
what he does he takes 90 that he moves
the Queen he might have Queen g3 at some
point navin that's not really going to
work also there's b6 as a liability nine
is currently kicking himself I think why
probably had a pretty good position
there if he goes f3 so I don't really
see a defenseman
now he takes d4 I'll go group g 7i think
yeah and here night h5 let's possibly
look c8 as a counter play look see it
and then I go Quinn to g5 probably night
h5 takes Queen edge form ok cannot think
all day
Jake's it Queen Queen edge for ya again
let's not threatening something directly
maybe I have a move that is more forcing
you might have bishop d 6 cm
now it's it's it's really not the end of
the world Queen g5 is also possible
maybe that is actually better to have
the direct threat
we can also take on Teague on be 6 cm
and okay I think it should it should win
no matter what ok didn't didn't think
about that
time morning night edge for a queen edge
for 492 check looks dangerous 92 check
maybe it's not a good idea to play for
this is one more threat but it's okay
fair to play move sometimes that's
definitely now threatening okay chess
get this in takes Queen f2 is made on g2
and King edge one this Bishop g2 might
resign from eight yeah this is this is
made now Wow yeah I don't know it was
probably nah he can draw he actually
okay it's a very very complicated game I
think I think he made a mistake if he
goes bf3 is much much better here
because well it takes me a while to
really get something going h5 g4 tilt it
still takes two moves to hit and way way
WAY long it's not not something quick
maybe g4 immediately and this is
something that I thought about like
night to be six and yeah there is this
rule that you need to keep this bishop
in the Kings Indian but the the rule is
really this is something important but
it's just about the fact that you often
need this bishop to get g4 in in the
first place when you have actually
managed g4 it's not such a big deal
sometimes that's a bishop is traded yeah
that's very difficult and you absolutely
cannot trust the engines in this
position right so it's absolutely not
advisable because they tend to yeah tend
to over al you over evaluate white space
in the center and this is it is quite
valid that there is a space but the
position is sometimes there are cases
where whites king it's in such a such
trouble that it does not really matter
that why this material up or crashing
through the computer is giving right
only a slight advantage here which makes
me think that probably black should be
okay simply because of the evaluation
function of the engine it wants to play
92 what I mean is normally they would
give white the engine would give why the
wind yeah in a typical Kings Indian
structure and if it doesn't give a win
it probably isn't that terrible for me
this is the computers main line whatever
whatever that's worth g5
back or hear whatever a root g 7 which
is seven maybe that's funny check funny
line yeah crazy that's given us equal
yeah but here I think he should play a
three after that I'm really not sure
what happens but the the situation gets
ultra complicated yeah he can take the
rook there but then I'd take him and
well at least I'm crashing through here
on the Kings side him if i'm not sure
what this is it's this but well I
definitely definitely what I want to get
him under pressure look here cheeks Jim
engine gives black a slight advantage
which is kind of how to how to figure
out now it switches to clear advantage
here maybe maybe this attack is too
strong this is a very funny line but
should reform what is this this is
supposed to be winning for black Queen
f6 queen air for attacking I'm a rope
down here well look for three pawns on a
wacky position yeah that sets the great
thing sometimes about the Kings Indian
you have positions that you will never
see in your life we are opening funny so
this is what a chocolaty I'm just
attacking 44 no material really G form
when TM okay the capture is the simplest
on a three and maybe I should have done
that actually yeah but it says probably
also when yeah it is it's it's winning
the whole time the night takes him yeah
okay yeah I was unsure but I have to
play move now and I went here for this
threat and hoping that there is nothing
much that he can do and yeah if he
allowed 92 check the comp gives Ruby to
with a slight edge for black
I don't know what a slight edge in this
position means we are what is this
actually I'm a pawn up yeah okay just to
make sure what the material count is not
that it matters so much oh you know
computer wants to play Queen f 6m
covering the spawn and gives black
almost to wind down now after some time
they're probably whites king is to shake
it but ok it stands right into the into
the mate this is check checkmate one
mate that's possible or if he goes there
the special ops we should check or hear
this again there should be a check Nate
I didn't see that actually shallowly I
only saw them make it made into it ok
funny game against yogurt thanks for
watching